this is terrifying that looks like
noodles
it looks like ramen hey guys my name is
how I work here at BuzzFeed and I spend
a lot of my time on Amazon looking for
different products and interesting items
and last week I was looking through
Amazon Japan's website and I found a
really interesting product that I think
we're gonna test out today okay so here
it is I'm on Amazon Japan's website I'm
looking at the bestsellers lists I'm
looking at the bestsellers in candy toys
so I didn't know what a candy toy was
but the best-selling candy toy in Japan
is this product called poppin cookin
[Music]
something so it's really intricate what
they do is they put together all of the
little pieces and it makes this tiny
little miniature ramen and the ramen is
like candy which i think is really cool
and really interesting so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna go up to the office and
I'm gonna snag some of my coworkers and
see if they want to try to attempt to
put together the ramen mix hey I'm Eric
and I'm feeling nervous hi I'm Tara and
I'm so ready for this I'm des Lisa and
I'm very nervous because I have no idea
what hell is about to make me do I'm so
excited because I love ramen candy ramen
well I'm actually I'm scared of ramen
off the bat it's so colorful this looks
exactly like stove top ramen it's like
party in the front business in the back
do you hang this reference oh okay good
I think I kind of get it
no feel good I feel good about this
actually I don't I still I feel like I
can't even read the English I'm too lazy
all right should I go for it should I do
this
cut the dumpling mold roundly with the
line I already [ __ ] up I feel it this
is why I hated like kindergarten this is
what kindergarten was made up of like a
lot of scissor cutting break a candy
[Music]
candy okay make a little little ball out
of this baboom this smells so sweet
survivor remaining candy in half and
expand them to the pastry bags guys but
like do they have a rolling pin because
I'm a sword they say don't play with
your food someone was like you know why
I'm gonna make food that you have to
play with please the expanded candies on
the dumpling mold and press them to make
Reese Reese's recesses Russell
recessives recesses ok I'm just gonna
look English is my second language
although my little pop rocks it was
supposed to be me and peas
we odd tastes like Dr Pepper ramen is
soda flavor dumpling a soda and cola
fair got it alright ok remove from the
mold and done you don't even have to
cook it no deep frying Q this is gonna
be so worth the wait
ok step 2 oh man there's so many stuff
pour water up to the line on the side of
the tray put the soup mix and mix it
well boom that's my soup bowl that's
some water great looks like sand I feel
really dumb and it's so upsetting
y'all I'm not even hungry for some candy
anymore I'm over it
I studied for 12 years in high school I
went to university like higher class
education I'm excited to see what the
noodles look like oh man I'm so
disappointing myself I'm like genuinely
upset Oh what chemical Oh some chemical
reaction is happening
one noodle about that that smells
amazing
this is like pee and poo pee over here
make a small hole at the corner of the
plastic bag with the with the pic from
the inside to the outside poke a hole
don't poco poco inside to the outside
that's not English from the inside to
the outside right Oh from the inside to
the outside that's like common sense I
understand now from the inside to the
outside it's not that complicated Eric
Oh little noodles looks like it looks
like dr. pimple popper kind of like
popping a pimple this is like those
gross pimple popping videos no I'm not
doing the last part they they got me all
the way messed up next step
press the remaining candy in the mold
and make the Naruto and the egg Naruto
and egg oh is that the name of this
thing that's a dish Naruto is not a
character yeah [ __ ] that Naruto and egg
what do I do it the dumpling power
decides it look how beautiful this is
is anyone appreciating this Wow honestly
I'm really proud of myself alright let's
try it
look at that amazing noodle
[Music]
it's so good oh my god when you eat
ramen you don't expected to taste like
soda and I'm just realizing it says soda
flavor on top I'm gonna be eating candy
ramen breakfast lunch dinner okay
let's talk about it so follow you my
dumpling I actually really enjoyed doing
this I thought it was super fun it's a
little messy would I do this again
possibly I could totally see myself just
sitting in my room all by myself and
making Japanese candy like for days I
give it three and a half stars
everything works like it said it was
gonna work I didn't make it pretty but
three stars for working but not tasting
so great out of five stars I give this
76 stars that's how good it is that can
you do that math how many how over five
did I go huh that's how good it is I
can't do that math but that's how over
it is 76 stars out of five stars
I said 71 oh I went over 71 stars oh
that's pretty easy math I shoulda known
[Music]